In this part of our tutorial we're going to talk about object oriented concepts as this is important to understand but not get a masterful meaning of
mainly in the terms of vocabulary and what I mean by that is something called a parent slash child class relationship.
Now in the diagram over here we have a biological family and this family has traits.
So the parents are the rectangular things up at the top and they have the ability to be blue, red or green.
Now underneath them are their children. So their children you can see here they have the ability to be red, blue or green
but there isn't the ability for them to select purple or orange or pink or some other color
because that is not a trait that was passed down to the children so they don't have that to choose from.
Now again this is a very simplistic look at how biology passes traits from their parents down to children
but the same thing can be applied to our code.
Inside of Unreal any class can be derived from making it a parent class and we can do this with blueprints
and the reason that we want to do this is a parent class can do things like set default values or predefined data or functions
that we want to start off with and then approve upon or adjust or even completely modify inside of the child.
This is because again a child is derived from an existing class and inside of a child we can override the parent's functionality
or default properties and this allows a child to extend the parent class or get more functionality out of it.
All classes are the child of another actor inside of Unreal up until UObject.
So UObject is the one master object so to speak or the master parent and everything is a child of UObject.
Now inheritance is something I further want to touch on as this is something that you're going to definitely come in contact
and you're already most likely using inside of all of your Unreal Engine projects
and inheritance is simply receiving variables, functions or macros, components and even default settings
from the class that is above it or its parent class and then utilizing those to do something interesting inside of the child.
One of the other things to keep in mind is that any changes to the parent will affect the child
unless the child overrides that value. So if we have a parent value set for health to 100,
child's default value for health is always going to be 100 unless they override that value.
If we decide at some point to change that health value to 120, all of the children that are made from that parent
will have that updated unless we've decided to change that health value to say something like 80.
All of the ones that we have changed will have that health value of 80 while all the rest will still have that new health value of 120.